TONIGHT.
THANKS A LOT, TRACE.
AS YOU JUST HEARD THE DEATH
COULD HAVE EASILY BEEN
PREVENTED IT WASN'T AN ACT
OF GOD OR SOME FREAK
ACCIDENT.
IT WASN'T EVEN A RANDOM
CRIME THE KIND THAT
INEVITABLY OCCURS IN A
COUNTRY AS LARGE AS OURS IS.
HER DEATH WAS THE PRODUCT OF
A DELIBERATE POLICY.
OUR LEADERSHIP CLASS HAS
DECIDED TO DOWN PLAY THE
THREAT OF MS-13.
WHY?
BECAUSE TRUMP ATTACKED
MS-13.
THEREFORE, IN THE COMMENTED DEMN
THEREFORE, IN THE COMMENTED DEME
THEREFORE, IN THE COMMENTED DEMD
ZERO SUM CALCULATION MS-13
MUST BE VIRTUOUS.
THE ENEMY OF DONALD TRUMP
MUST BE MY FRIEND.
THAT'S HOW THEY THINK.
IT ALL STARTED ALMOST EXACT
LAY YEAR AGO WHEN THE
PRESIDENT SAID.
THIS.
>> SO WHEN THE MS-13 COMES
IN WHEN THE OTHER GANG
MEMBERS COME INTO OUR
COUNTRY I REFER TO THEM AS
ANIMALS, AND GUESS WHAT?
I ALWAYS WILL.
>> Tucker: KEEP IN MIND
MS-13'S MOTTO IS KILL, RAPE,
CONTROL.
THEY ROUTINELY TORTURE AND
MURDER HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
THEY BRING DRUGS ACROSS THE
BORDER AND INTO OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
THEY ARE THE DEADLIEST
CRIMINAL GANG IN AMERICA.
YET, ONCE TRUMP ATTACKED
THEM, THE LEFT DECIDED THAT
WORRYING ABOUT MS-13 WAS A
GREATER THREAT TO OUR VALUES
THAN THE GANG ITSELF.
ANYONE WHO CRITICIZED MS-13
WAS DENOUNCED AS RACIST IF
NOT A TOOL OF PUTIN.
THEY SAID AS MUCH OUT LOUD,
INCLUDING ON THIS SHOW.
THE TRADITIONAL DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, THE ONE THAT
REPRESENTED BLUE COLLAR
AMERICA WOULD HAVE BEEN
BAFFLED BY THIS.
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE OF ALL
COLORS ARE ALWAYS THE
BIGGEST VICTIMS OF CRIME.
IF YOU WANT TO PROTECT THEM,
DON'T SIDE WITH CRIMINALS.
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT
DEMOCRATS, INCLUDING A YOUNG
JOE BIDEN ONCE UNDERSTOOD
INTUITIVELY BUT NO LONGER.
TODAY CRITICIZING MS-13
WOULD MEAN ASKING QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE PARTY'S ORTHODOXY
ON IMMIGRATION.
IT WOULD EXPOSE NANCY
PELOSI'S ABSURD LIE THAT
EVERY SINGLE IMMIGRANT IS
IMPRESSIVE AND MUST BE
ALLOWED TO STAY IN THE
COUNTRY, NO QUESTIONS ASKED.
NOBODY ON THE LEFT WANTS TO
TALK ABOUT ANY OF THIS.
SO, INSTEAD, THEY JUST
DEFENDED MS-13.
>> HE BASICALLY SEEMS TO
ASSUME THAT EVERYBODY IS
PART OF MS-13.
VERY STRANGE TO HEAR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES SPEAK IN SUCH
DEHUMANIZING TERMS.
>> IS IT APPROPRIATE FOR A
PRESIDENT EVER TO CALL NIP
AN ANIMAL EVEN IF THEY'RE IS
A DISSTICK GANG MEMBERS.
>> YEAH.
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING TO
LOOK OUT FOR.
THE HISTORY OF POLITICAL
LEADERS DEHUMANIZING PONIES
AND CRIMINALS AND USING
ANIMAL METAPHORS IS A
DANGEROUS ONE.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD ACCEPT FROM AN
AMERICAN PRESIDENT.
>> I DO THINK THERE IS A
SERIOUS PROBLEM WITH THE
PRESIDENT DEHUMANIZING ANY
GROUP OF PEOPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES, EVEN IF
THEY'RE HARDENED CRIMINALS.
>> Tucker: GOT THAT?
SAYING RUDE THINGS ABOUT
MS-13 IS A, QUOTE:  SERIOUS
PROBLEM UNLIKE SAY ABORTION
UP TO THE MOMENT OF BIRTH
WHICH IS LIBERATION AND NOT
A PROBLEM AT ALL.
THAT'S NANCY PELOSI'S
POSITION.
PELOSI CONSIDERS LATE TERM
ABORTION AS WHOLESOME AS A
PICNIC.
GANG MEMBER FACE TATTOO AND
GIVE YOU A LONG LECTURE
ABOUT GOD.
>> WE ARE ALL GOD'S
CHILDREN.
THERE IS A SPARK OF DIVINITY
IN EVERY PERSON ON EARTH.
AND SO WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES SAYS ABOUT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS,
THESE AREN'T PEOPLE.
THESE ARE ANIMALS, YOU HAVE
TO WONDER DOES HE NOT
BELIEVE IN THE SPARK OF
DIVINITY, THE DIGNITY AND
WORTH OF EVERY PERSON?
EVERY DAY THAT YOU THINK
YOU'VE SEEN IT ALL ALONG
COMES ANOTHER MANIFESTATION
OF WHY THEIR POLICIES ARE SO
INHUMANE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S TODAY'S
LECTURE ON CHRISTIANITY FROM
NANCY PELOSI.
THE MEDIA, OF COURSE,
DUTIFULLY AMPLIFIED PELOSI'S
MESSAGE SHE IS THEIR BOSS.
THAT'S THEIR JOB.
VOXX.COM PRODUCED ENTIRE
VIDEO TO EXPLAIN THAT
ACTUALLY MS-13 MEMBERS ARE
JUST LIKE YOUR KID.
>> WHEN YOU THINK OF THE
STREET GANG MS-13, WHAT DO
YOU SEE?
MAYBE SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
OR THIS.
BUT WHAT IF I TOLD YOU THAT
TYPICAL MS-13 GANG MEMBER IN
THE U.S. ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE
ONE OF THESE YOUNG MEN ON
FACEBOOK?
>> THE MS-13 13 MEMBERS THAT
I HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING ARE
WORKING AFTER SCHOOL JOBS.
THEY ARE LIVING WITH THEIR
PARENTS.
THEY GET AROUND LONG ISLAND
ON BICYCLES.
>> THERE IS NO INDICATION
THAT WE ARE SEEING A BIGGER
SURGE OF MS-13 THAN WE HAVE
SEEN IN THE PAST.
>> Tucker: WHEN THE
REVOLUTION FINALLY ENDS,
WHEN THIS ERA, THIS MOMENT,
WHATEVER WE ARE IN RIGHT NOW
WHEN IT FINALLY ENDS, THAT
VIDEO YOU JUST SAW FROM
VOX.COM A PERIOD PIECE.
HARD TO BELIEVE THAT'S REAL
BUT IT IS REAL THAT KIND OF
PROPAGANDA WHERE POWERFUL
PEOPLE ARE LYING RIGHT TO
YOUR FACE AGAIN AND AGAIN
AND AGAIN.
IT HAPPENS A LOT.
IT WILL BE PRETTY FUNNY,
ACTUALLY, IF THE STAKES WERE
LOWER BUT THEY ARE NOT LOW.
THEY ARE HIGH.
LEFT LEFT GEFNEDZ MS-13
CAN'T DOWN SIZE THE PROBLEM
THEY GAVE US.
WHO KNOWS WHERE IT MIGHT